بسنواتها 18 تقف مروه على قارعه الطريق في
كابول لكن في قلب الحدث
ترفع فوق راسها لوحه تحدي لقرار طالبان
القاضي باخراج الفتيات من الجامعات
والنساء العاملات من دائره الاقتصاد
وادخالهن دوامه الجهل والبطاله والفقر
بكلمه واحده تواجه ابنه جيل ما بعد طالبان
مقاتل الحركه الذين قفزوا الى السلطه بعد
عقدين من المبيت في الكهوف والجبال اقرا
تريد مروه من قيادات طالبان ان تقرا في
صفحه مستقبل افغانستان لا ماضيها
بالنسبه لها ما هو اهم من المصالحه
الوطنيه التي اخرجت الرئيس الافغاني فار
من البلاد واخضعت مقاتلي وادي بشير
الاسطوري
المصالحه مع المجتمع الافغاني نصفه تحديدا
لا شل هو تعطيله
ان فتاه واحده وقفت ضد طالبان فان ذلك
سيساعدهن على النهوض وهزيمه طالبان
تقف مروه على هذا الطريق وحدها لكن ليست
وحيده
خلفها تيار كبير يرفض مشهد السلاح طالبان
على حقوق المراه
مشهد يؤكد ان المراه والفتاه الافغانيه لا
تقلان فيه شجاعه عن الرجل الافغاني